and
can I was I you know attracted to the
men maybe finally know that I'm gay
[Music]
so there's people on Reddit that have
been talking a lot about things they
didn't know until they lived with a
woman
and we're gonna read these These are
good if we that women fart
what's that what women don't fart dude
we're gonna read these and see if we can
relate I'm gonna read these out to you
okay
this one says um she'll let you believe
you were clogging the toilet when it was
really her
has that ever happened not yet no not
yet never happens that's never happened
think real hard are you sure draining
the shower type stuff because the hair
100 yeah
dude when you learn how to snake it out
though you feel like oh dude it's crazy
you can start my own Plumbing business
what the [ __ ] you get a new LLC use a
wire hanger oh I tried doing that it
didn't really work but I went to get a
snake the snake is much better oh you
actually got the snake I bought the
snake you're not a handyman you're like
a handy boy around your house when you
uh when things belong to you and you
choose to keep it in a certain place
like on a shelf or in a specific drawer
um and she says that it shouldn't be
there and it should be somewhere else
does that ever happen thankfully no oh
that does happen Okay well she won't
even tell me I'm like dude it was right
here where is it she was like I'm like
even if it's yours you put it here last
time so why is it somewhere
it doesn't make sense because that's a
that's a popular uh meme about how like
men can never find anything because it's
like always gets moved around but it's
really just right there yeah it's like
off a little bit then you just can't see
it I'll say this about Tiff
she'll Panic like looking for stuff and
it's bright under her like right in her
nose all the time oh so she'll like
misplace things and she'll be looking
everywhere but it's [ __ ] right there
but does she do that with your things
that she doesn't even use no no she does
it's nice thank God we're all psyched
for good
you know um have you ever I know I
totally know you get me no I don't in
your home has she ever hung her bra
somewhere that it normally wouldn't be
on yeah doorknob
getting it I'm like right here she hangs
her bra right here on his chest wow uh
do you ever pick it up and try to wear
it absolutely yeah boys boys come on no
that's a thing yeah what do you do once
it's on do a little sexy walk you know
no whoa do that again I go hey babe look
and I do that and oh so she's there
against killer Nick's probably like that
it's a hit and she's just a [ __ ]
groaning note the reviews are in the
reviews it's a hot show it's a hot show
it's bra only nothing else like yeah
people were saying that like they'll
find the bra hanging on a doorknob or on
a bed post end table Yeah you ever find
just bras somewhere I feel like that
happened a lot when like was younger I
feel like nowadays uh more contained as
a older you know where the [ __ ] goes all
right how about this the way that you
fold the towels is incorrect excuse me
that's never happened to you either no
because I always folded the towels oh so
your girl never did that no don't you
just like corn or corner and then flip
over you're not making swans
this guy's saying that he does the
tri-fold and that his his wife wants to
do the double so they get in a little
thing about it which one saves more
space though dude these people have too
much time on there yeah I think that um
who gives a [ __ ] hey good job three
times doesn't I make it like thicker so
then you actually lose room yeah it's
well it's you lose 3D room but it's
still I think it depends on your cabinet
oh and where you put the [ __ ] towel
it's not a rack I guess that's different
or efficient yeah it's like if you got a
thin cabinet you're gonna do whatever
the [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] fold how about
this no matter how many bobby pins are
in the house there's always a need for
more that makes sense I've used the
bobby pins and it makes sense because
you always just lose them hair ties the
hair ties yeah hair ties are all yeah my
cats take the hair ties not yeah not
really there's always like a a specific
place for him thankfully
um
these are good questions finding hair in
the shower and you think it's spider no
I think they're spiders all the time and
it's always we may not be the average
guy who wrote this but also to come like
does your girls like do they shed a lot
of hair like does my girl like lose hair
and then put in eight [ __ ] legs no
but no no but sometimes they get clumped
up like if you have like a washing
machine sometimes when you're washing
clothes every now and then you'll get
like a clump of hair that just is on the
floor and you'll I I've been there it
looks like a spider but it's not you
realize it's hair and then you throw it
away I mean I get it but it's not a big
deal I mean there's always hair in a
clump somewhere and she's always waiting
for me to throw it away in the shower
yeah I remember those yeah yeah but like
I never think it's your job to throw it
away she she likes to leave me little
treats of work
there for like a week oh yeah yes it's
my turn
how about
um has your girl wait let me just ask
you this do you like having a trash can
in the bathroom yeah yeah yeah that's
where when you're done with the toilet
paper you put the little yeah what do
you wipe yeah I you know what's funny
maybe white dudes don't what is that
true why are you looking at me like I
have affirmations because these guys are
acting like women made them put up trash
can in the bathroom if you guys
commonplace right but that's like Asians
always have trash cans in the bathroom
right yeah we've always had a trash can
yeah I mean you go to a hotel and
there's always a trash can in the back I
definitely understand how it makes a lot
more sense for women automatically yeah
but I think there's total convenience
for a guy to have trash in the bathroom
in general right whether it's like
clipping your [ __ ] nails to like
throwing away a Q-tip to like throwing
away disposable contacts or like you
know what I mean I think it's like
something else yeah what do you want me
to say it's the word you still use
condoms dude you have sex still
this is good we're disagreeing with a
lot of this that's good so another
person says God knows where my hands
have been if she likes a candle in the
house that either means the house stinks
or she wants to have sex definitely not
sexy definitely the house stinks
my girl burns incense I love incense
what does that mean I don't know I mean
she's a horny dog because she wants it
comment below if you guys got any ideas
or are the feng shui's bad so they got a
lot of incense you know my girl don't
know what feng shui is I should be
taunted that's why yeah it's haunted
dude if it's haunted I'm [ __ ] out how
about uh these men have discovered that
RuPaul's Drag Race is a great show you
know what I hear it's a good show yeah
there's some white [ __ ] dude these are
white dudes I'm not gonna lie I took uh
I took Nina for uh like our anniversary
to the Vegas show the live show and
can I was I you know attracted to the
men maybe yeah you know because you
heard it it's good to understand that by
yourself man yeah what did I even share
right now was that even cool should I
take that but can we edit that out yeah
no edit it in more louder repeat it yeah
can I was I you know attracted to the
men maybe we haven't watched the TV show
but we have seen a live one can you make
that like the the bumper clip in the
beginning that little preview for the so
people know what they're in for so if
you want you guys finally know that I'm
gay you're gay dude that's weird no it
doesn't have the fourth wall thing I did
again you see that how about this
Kevin's mine's balloon
first time that you lived with a woman
did you uh did you feel like wow there's
a lot of steps before they can go to
sleep like the stuff they do in the
bathroom before going to bed I'm still
learning
that [ __ ] I feel like it's a lot more
what does she do yeah before it's like
uh you know when you like first start
dating I feel like they're not trying to
show you how much craziness they might
even go to sleep with makeup on you know
try to wake up pretty or some [ __ ] right
the more comfortable you get the crazier
stuff gets right like a bridesmaids like
that yeah exactly nowadays it's like
it's like two hours before they go to
sleep two hours wow you know what I mean
I'll like go to sleep we'll start
brushing our teeth at the same time I'll
go to sleep wake up for work and she'll
still be like doing [ __ ] like what so
what kind of stuff did does she do
before bed I don't have like the [ __ ]
scientific names for this stuff but just
just get name them yourself scientific
name complicated but there's you know
there's a lot of skin stuff oh like
moisturize and I understand right
because when you're like taking off like
random layers whether it be like you
know not saying there's makeup all the
time but yeah you gotta clean your pores
right yeah exactly but it's like there's
like four different layers and then it's
like you got to put on this type of like
mask and then you gotta like have it sit
there for 10 to 15 minutes so that's
when you get in bed a book and after the
alarm goes off you got to go back you
got to take off that thing add this
other thing she does that every night
every night when I okay nobody this is
not gonna make any sense I swear to God
sometimes when I wash my face right
my pores open up and then I get pimples
oh that makes sense felt that though I
feel like I when I used to wash my face
as a kid it's when the pimples came so I
never I never so I know I don't use face
wash I'll like throw like rinse and do
all this stuff but like now that I don't
do that I feel like my natural oils or
whatever I'm like pretty good with it
she like hates me for it you ever think
that it's like a dirty towel after you
wash your face your pores open up you
put the dirt into your face it could be
yeah because a lot of towels are dirtier
than we think yeah that's true Tan's got
great skin but dude I think my nighttime
routine is pretty long too because I
recently got braces off so I have to do
like retainers and do all this [ __ ] and
like you know and then 25 minutes of
this [ __ ] yeah yeah you just had a
retainer yeah and I got a floss and [ __ ]
too oh but that's you know but but
normally people only floss like every
other I have to do it every day because
now the teeth I've shifted there's like
holes where the food is always you'll do
the little like the little [ __ ] bows
or whatever sometimes they get stuck in
my teeth y'all but anyways what's next
what's the next thing they get stuck
yeah yeah cause I got I got like crazy I
gotta like start freaking out one of my
molars is like cracked in the back so it
always gets stuck on there I thought you
were perfect it's a disappointment it's
like [ __ ] up actually I should see
somebody
so that is pretty much the last one
um and then I think there's a nice one
at the end that says like it's nice to
have someone around that gets excited
for you
what else what else happens that you
guys see in your in your significant
other stuff
is there anything that pisses you off a
little bit no no one thing for me that I
noticed once I started Living with a
girl was the toilet seat [ __ ] it's like
what oh believe you just leave it up
[ __ ] out of the toilet seat
you're in a house full of guys it's like
the toilet seat is just up but then when
you start living with a girl it starts
it's always down now so it's like oh
[ __ ] I gotta lift it up if I want to use
it you want to know a little uh sad hack
if you want to know if another dude has
been in your house and has taken a piss
what look under the seat because there's
always a little tinkle
um so if you just cleaned it and that
[ __ ] appear as women can't make that
happen they don't know how
Ryan is zany who's wild that's it yeah
turn it off dude
[ __ ] video dog I got a piece so bad
[Music]